bonjour david lee wong merci d'être avec
nous en direct alors première question
quel est l'objectif de ce mémoire faire
pression donc tout à fait ses mémoires
en fait objectif de faire pression sur
le conseil constitutionnel ce n'est pas
un recours en tant que tel mais pour
alerter le conseil constitutionnel sur
la violation en fait de différentes
dispositions de la constitution la
déclaration des droits de l'homme
puisque c'est cette loi en fait porte
atteinte à la liberté liberté
individuelle normalement notamment
pardon bodereau travail à la liberté de
circuler et qu'elle porte atteinte aussi
à l'intégrité physique à la dignité des
personnes
faut savoir que cette fois en fête a été
rédigé et voter rapidement et le
législateur n'a pas pris soin de mettre
des garde-fous concernant les libertés
constitutionnelles des personnes alors
le collectif dénonce une entrave à la
liberté d'aller et venir des citoyens
ainsi que les conséquences du projet de
loi en matière de droit du travail tout
à fait ici là vraiment où cela pose
d'énormes difficultés d'application
puisque on permet à l'employeur en fait
de contrôler à ce que les salariés et
leurs passes sanitaires donc il s'agit
également d'une violation du secret
médical et d'atteinte à la vie privée
en plus cette loi prévoit une suspension
du contrat de travail mais il ne précise
pas ce qu'il en est ce si le salarié ne
présente pas son passé à knitter alors
qu'un projet initial prévoyait en fait
que le salarié sera licencié avec ses
amis et les gars là la loi ne prévoit
rien sous pression du medef
ce qui fait que le salarié respect en
peine de se faire licencier
malheureusement pour faute grave puisque
l'employeur je le rappelle est tenu de
préserver la santé physique et mentale
de ses salariés alors le conseil
constitutionnel doit rendre son avis
demain et sera sans doute favorable
c'est le début d'une bataille juridique
pour vous tout à fait mais bon si je ne
vois pas comment on fait le con
séquentiel pour attacher sur à cette
fois tant de liberté habituel
individuelles sont piétinés par par
cette fois donc effectivement ce sera
une des procès à venir notamment devant
tu te vends les conseillers des
prud'hommes mais malheureusement si le
conséquence yann considère que cette loi
est conforme à la constitution et au
bloc de constitutionnalité faudra faudra
vraiment s'inquiéter en l'avenir parce
que sous prétexte de l'urgence sanitaire
va le gouvernement le des pouvoirs
publics
le parlement pourra prendre en fait
toutes les mesures qu'il estime
malheureusement adéquates sans aucun un
subtil de nos libertés
les français qui sont également partagés
concernant ce projet de loi on l'a
encore vu la semaine dernière plus de
deux cent mille personnes ont manifesté
à travers la france alors qu'on est en
plein été la rentrée s'annonce explosive
il n'y a pas que la route rien qui
s'annonce explosive
tu fais des projets du gouvernement
concernant notamment la science chômage
et à la réforme des retraites les
manifestations vont continuer
aujourd'hui vous aviez manifestez vous
avez une manifestation et midi à cazaux
2010 à 14 heures place du palais royal
ils demain toute la journée par des
personnes ont également manifesté donc
deux places du palais royal à proximité
du conseil constitutionnel pour demander
à ce que cette fois soit jugée
inconstitutionnelle et samedi se voit là
samedi prochain est en contact avec les
organisateurs des manifestations anti
pas sanitaire beh
une manifestation déclarée et est
produit ce samedi
merci beaucoup en tout cas d'avis à
paris en tout cas merci beaucoup
david levin skin d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes un
bon avocat au barreau de paris et co
fondateur du collectif robe noir et
gilet jaune